[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they come in so it is
time to see then what is making the
headlines with the columnist carol
malone and the political editor of the
liverpool echo liam thorpe welcome to
both of you so to the front pages then
let us start with
the metro
the front of the metro covering the
channel migrant crisis their headline we
just want to live like you
my wife was on the boat i tracked the
gps then it disappeared a migrant
husband's anguish on the front page of
the telegraph
the delhi mirror looks at the boats that
carry people trying to cross the channel
their headline the diy death boats
the daily express looks at plans for
british troops to patrol french beaches
as both the uk and france attempt to
tackle migrant crossings
the front of the financial times covers
britain and france's clash over the
political response to the tragedy
in other news the guardian covers
reports of a new covid variant and
changes to travel restrictions
while the times also leads with covid
their headline variant halts travel to
africa
well we're joined now by carol malone
and liam thorpe welcome to both of you
as you can see i'm on a very blustery uh
calais shoreline here uh let's start
then shall we with the metro we just
want to live like you and certainly
carol the tragedy of yesterday is
banging heads together politically now
do you think it will get anywhere
i i just think it absolutely has to you
know the tragedy here is that
what's
this tragic needless loss of life we
knew was coming we always knew it was
coming you know from the day she was
installed as home secretary pretty patel
has been saying this would happen and
she was saying one of these boats would
bump into a container ship or be hit by
something and that appears to be exactly
what has happened so the biggest tragedy
is here that it could have been stopped
so yes boris is talking tonight about
and there's going to be a deal with the
french where we can send people back
immediately and they arrive
um and they can be processed over there
so you know it's a thing they are
talking about you know what we've had
lots of talks with the french before
macron is being very very bullish today
he's trying to blame us he's actually
saying to boris don't don't you exploit
this or capitalize on this which is
outrageous coming from him because this
is what he's been he's been using this
migrant crisis to beat britain with four
four months now he could easily have
stopped this he could easily have made
these crossings fewer and less he could
have boosted border patrols indeed he's
paid millions to to have to have these
border controls boosted millions have
come from britain to do that and he
hasn't done it every time we see
migrants piling into these boats in
france you know 50 on a boat in bad
weather conditions we see maybe one
police patrol car and cops standing by
smoking and and having a cup of coffee
that's not patrolling our borders so
boris wants our troops over there to
help the french petroleum but you know
macron doesn't want our troops our
people are our border patrols over there
he's already said that so i'm hoping
very much that he gets he comes down
from his high horse now in the face of
this tragedy and and tries to stop this
happening ever again
but but that seems to be the only tactic
doesn't it actually to stop this as a
route to enter the country uh and
everybody pointing us out to us tonight
that there is no safe asylum route to
the uk that that's the bit that needs to
change uh but liam take us through the
daily telegraph if you can this first
person account of somebody who fears
that their wife was on this boat
yeah so we've seen a couple of of these
really human stories based around this
tragedy whether it's this story in the
telegraph or what you just referred to
in the metro which is that people are
actually still trying this route today
you know the day after 27 people so
tragically drowned in the most horrific
of circumstances the story in the
telegraph is is about um the husband of
an iraqi kurdish woman who beli he
believes was on the boat he has lost
contact with her he was tracking her
movements uh using gps and then lost
contact and and i think what's really
important about this story which seems
to get lost a lot in a lot of the
rhetoric and a lot of the really grim
and horrible comments that i see on
social media about this crisis is that
people who are trying to get to this
country usually have a very very
compelling reason to to try and do that
if you know if i always ask people to
put themselves in the situation of
someone in such a desperate place if you
are if your family your only loved one
the people you care about the most are
in the uk it's the only place that you
know how to speak the language the only
place you possibly think you could have
any hope of of achieving a life that you
want that's why they're trying to get
here it's not just a case of they you
know as so many people seem to want to
think they just want to come here for an
easy ride it's simply not the case when
you look at the statistics 98 of the
people trying to attempt this crossing
are asylum seekers they're coming from
places of persecution of war of having
the most difficult times any of us could
imagine and they want to try and link up
with either family members or a
situation where they feel that they can
have a life and that's the case with
this tragic situation with mrs nuri uh
reported in the telegraph today where
she's suddenly she sadly tried to
reconnect with her husband and has died
in the most horrific of circumstances
just to pick up on what you said there
beforehand the thing that is not being
mentioned we're talking about patrols
we're talking about these kind of
hardline tactics we are not talking
about the fact that if there were more
safe options more safe routes then
people would have different ways to try
to to legally get into the country and
i'm afraid this government is completely
completely responsible for shutting
those routes down and forcing more
people to try and attempt this
incredibly dangerous crossing
yeah and just in 30 seconds the big
issue on a number of the papers the mail
they express the times too is this idea
of joint patrols actually on the beaches
i mean the french president has an
election next spring that's a
sovereignty issue as far as he's
concerned and he's he's not happy about
that suggestion carol
he's not happy at all and he has said so
in the past well he felt he said so in
recent days but i don't know how he can
object to that now when he says the
british have to do more what does he
mean more throwing money at him hasn't
worked so the only thing more that we
can do is to be there on the beaches
with his people
carol thank you very much you need
plenty more still to come we will be
taking a full look at those new warnings
about a new variant on covid back in
just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the columnist
carol malone and the political editor of
the liverpool echo liam thorpe uh liam
let's turn our attention to covid shall
we now and this warning about a new
variant and of course the closure of
certain routes from africa starting
tomorrow
yeah absolutely it's a it's a sort of
scary reminder really of of the threat
that cobra still still poses you know
that
much of life of course has got back to
normal in this country and we know about
the the growing uh rise of the epidemic
in in europe but
it is still the the new variants that
are probably the biggest concern and and
this variant which is the b11529 variant
which um believes to originate in south
africa is a real concern we've seen some
scientists talking about it and growing
increasingly concerned about it the the
fear is not only that it's more
transmissible than delta but that it has
potential the potential to evade
vaccines and evade immunity of course
you know the uk government has thrown
all of its weight behind the the vaccine
program that is our only form of defense
that we're using and and obviously it
has it has been rolled out well it has
been working in many ways here if you
then get a variant that potentially
comes into the country that can invade
those vaccines then we're in trouble so
that's why sanji javid has taken the
action today to reinstall the red list
the six countries from southern africa
that will be on the red list from midday
tomorrow and and they're going to be
tracking down anyone who has arrived
recently from south africa so yeah it's
just a really strong warning about the
the the
the variance and the dangers that they
can still pose to us
yeah just quickly on this then carol
obviously a lot of people do that
journey to south africa you've got
christmas coming you've got families
moving it'd be a great disappointment to
them and to to the airlines but i mean
is it right to stay safe on this one i
mean if you throw everything into your
vaccine basket you've got to protect
that haven't you
oh my god yes you know this country has
been really slow in the past to move
when when variants have come over here
and it has been very costly in terms of
sickness and people catching the virus
so this is absolutely the right thing to
do
you know we should you know it it there
are lots of variants that have come with
these fires and and we don't know you
know some of them look really bad on
paper we don't know whether this one is
going to be really bad yet scientists
have said it's the worst one we've seen
so far but say a lot of them did look
bad and we don't know how fast it's
going to spread in higher vaccinated
countries south africa has a vaccination
rate of just 24
so it has spread there it may be the
case and hopefully fingers crossed that
in
more highly vaccinated countries it does
not spread so fast but you know we have
to wait and see what the scientists say
and until there's some proper data on it
uh carol liam i know you wanted to talk
about the fact that uh richard madeley
is out of i'm a celebrity well you could
actually call carol but i say carol
maybe it's a liam story i'm not quite
sure whichever one of you wants to tell
me about it in there in 10 seconds
quickly
the richard maddy was done he was diving
in a big thing of fish gotten rotten
fruit and vegetables anyway after he
came out he got sick in the night he'd
been complaining about the cold and he
had to be taken to hospital in the early
hours of the morning and now he's been a
he's got to come out
great music
carol
[Music]